plus three percent what does that number
tell us the world economy has grown in
2014 and plus three percent maybe even a
little bit more is expected for this
year and also for the coming years now
is that good news or is that bad news
hola Roco from deutsche bank research if
we look at the current business mood and
the four biggest world economies is
there much cause for celebration or what
is the divx telling us it's still a bit
mixed certainly we had a decline of the
divx in december driven by a declines in
sentiment especially of the united
states while we had improvement in
germany actually some stabilization in
China and a bit of an increase in Japan
and so far it's a bit of mixed picture
but I would certainly agree that 2015
should see a bit better growth than 2014
oil prices obviously remained very very
salient topping for the world economy
right now the price decline is getting
quite dramatic these days is that now
occurs or is that a blessing for the
world economy it's mixed again
unfortunately in total we would suggest
that it's good for the global economy
lower oil prices bolster real incomes as
well as with consumption in the
industrial nations which are mostly
consumers net consumers of oil well
certainly producers of oil like Saudi
Arabia Russia and even the US to some
extent at least could not benefit from
this they are net exports might decline
a bit investment might decline but in
total if it's good for the world economy
how's that story going to continue your
colleagues from Goldman Sachs are
expecting the oil prices to even drop
further to around 40 US dollars per
barrel is that something that you think
is very realistic well we've recently
cut our own forecast to around 60 US
dollars per barrels from 80 before from
100 before so it's really an
unprecedented nearly unfair
the decline in the oil price and it's
uncertain where this guy decline will
end could it go to forty dollars
certainly but it might as well not it's
really difficult to say but even at the
current levels of roughly fifty dollars
it's still a benefit to the global
economy let's look at Europe where
inflation remains extremely low the
option of a comprehensive bond
purchasing program by the ECB has been a
highly highly controversial topic of
discussion do you think that is the
right impulse for the European economy
in total it's probably necessary a the
simple truth is inflation and slower
growth is only moderate the oil price
will weigh on inflation although my
tetas growth all told the ECB is
basically out of ammunition for
conventional policies that's why it's
setting its course towards
unconventional policies for example
purchases of government bonds it's left
to right cross probably because it has a
mandate of two percent inflation rate
and this purchase of a government bonds
through a lower exchange rate for
example might help there but in the end
only these structural reforms in most
countries of Europe will help for more
sustained growth and more sustained
inflation levels low inflation is not
the only topic on Europe's problem
agenda right now in times of the much
disputed pegida protests immigration is
another topic for controversial
discussions we want to approach that
subject in a very sober in a fact-based
manner in our focus interview of this
week immigration and the economy you can
see that online it's DW de / english /
mate in germany